[موسيقى]
طب تم طابته اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار
الساعه نبداها بابرز العناوين
[موسيقى]
اداؤهن بحجم نهائي كاس العالم هل
الارجنتين تنتزع الفوز من فرنسا بركلات
الترجيح
وتتوجوا بطله بعد 36 عاما
بعد قتال شرس حتى النفس الاخير بابي هداف
مونديال 2022 وميسي افضل لاعب
بريطانيا تتخذون نهجا حذرا في حرب
اوكرانيا وتلمح لي وقف الدعم العسكري عن
كيف وتبدي تقاربا جزئيا مع موسكو
[موسيقى]
تودع ابنها الرابعه العربيه تلتقي والده
الضابط الذي قتل في اعمال الشغب الاخير
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مباراه تليق بنهايه كاس العالم
ملعب لوسيل في قطر تحول ساحه حرب شرسه بين
فرنسا والارجنتين قتل فيها المنتخبان حتى
النفس الاخير مباراه ممتعه تاريخيه وايضا
صعبه بعد ان تنفس الارجنتين الصعداء
بهدفين مقابل 0 في الشوط الاول عادلت
فرنسا النتيجه في الشوط الثاني بهدفين
الاول جاء من ركله جزاء والثاني بعدها
بدقه قليله في الشوطين الاضافيين سجل كل
من منتخبي منتخب الارجنتين ومنتخب منتخب
فرنسا هدف لتنتهي المباراه باشواتها
الاصليه بثلاثه اهداف لكل منتخب ركلات
الجزاء كانت الحزم انتزعت الارجنتين الفوز
ولقبت بطله لكاس العالم لهذا المونديال
2022 بعد 36 عاما على اخر مره ت بهذا
اللقب وها هي تضيفا النجم الثالثه بهذا
الفوز على قميصها
نتابع هذه الاحتفالات في بيونس ايرس
والدوحه بينما باريس بدات شوارعها تخلف من
المشجعين بعد خسارتها امام الارجنتين اذن
هذه هي الجماهير
الارجنتيني من بيونس الاحتفالات الاكبر
منذ اليوم قبل المباراه كان الحديث يدور
ان الشوارع الرئيسيه قد تخلوا من المشجعين
العديد انتشروا في الساحات منتظرين بدايه
او سافره البدايه لمباراه اليوم التي توج
بها منتخب الارجنتين كان هناك قبل ذلك وهي
الهدافات التاريخيه المعهوده بين جماهير
البرازيل وجماهير الى الارجنتين جماهير
الارجنتين كانت تقول وتتغنى بمرادونا
وتتغنى ايضا
بليونيل ميسي هذا اللاعب الذي جلب له
الكاس بعد جلابه
دونا بعدها 36 عاما او قبل 36 عاما اليوم
يعيد الكاره ليونيل ميسي ليكون افضل لاعب
في هذا المونديال وافضل لاعب في العالم
دعونا نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي من هناك
وهتافات الجماهير
[تصفيق]
الى الدوحه من هناك معي ليث بزاري وايضا
نايف في الثقيل حياكم الله
ليث يقال ان انت خلي يبدا ويا ليث وارجع
لك يا نايف ليث يقولون انت في الممر اللي
قد يخرج من المنتخب
الارجنتيني قد يكون ممر الشرف هذا اليوم
[موسيقى]
نعم عادل نحن هنا وبشكل حصري لقناه
العربيه
المكان الذي سيقطعه المنتخب الفائز بكاس
العالم قطر 2022 المنتخب الارجنتيني
بقياده ميسي سوف ينتقل المنتخب او اعضاء
المنتخب الارجنتيني من ملعب الحسين من
استاد الوزير خلف هذه الكاميرا الى هنا
ليحيوا الجمهور الذي يصطف على جنب الطريق
نشاهد الجميع هنا ينتظر هذا الموقف وهناك
طبعا من يحمل اعلام قطر المغرب البحرين
السعوديه الارجنتين وجميع الدول وجميع
المشجعون تجدهم في هذه في هذا الممر في
هذا الدرس ضرب الاستاذ الذي ينتهي عند اخر
هذا الممر في عمق الصوره في منطقه الابراج
واذا شاهدنا جيدا عادل يوجد قوات امن كل
متر او نصف متر ونصف المت يوجد شرطي وهم
يقومون بحراسه هذه المنطقه حتى لا يدخلها
من المهووسين برميسي او القاء نفسهم امام
الحافله التي ستقل هؤلاء اللاعبين وبعد
ذلك اذا نظرنا في الصوره سنشاهد الاعلام
الارجنتينيه التي تلوح الكترونيا في
المنطقه وهذه طبعا هي المنطقه الاشهر هنا
في الدوحه التي يقصدها الكثير من المشجعين
ومن الذين ياتون الى استاذ وليس فقط هم
الكثير من الذين يحبون التنزه في الدوحه
ياتون الى هذه المنطقه الجديده ويصادف
اليوم هو اليوم الوطني للقطر الثامن عشر
من ديسمبر وشاهدنا كثير من الذين اتىوا مع
اطفالهم عادا الذين اتوا الى الملعب
لتشجيع المنتخب الارجنتيني او ميسي تحديدا
شاهدنا الكثير الذين اتوا فقط لمشاهده
الاجواء لرص الاجواء وعايشه تلك الاجواء
اجواء الفوز بكاس العالم مره اخرى في
مونديال قطر 2022 واذا اخذنا الصوره هذا
من الجهه الاخرى سوف نشاهد الكثير من رجال
الامن الذين يعني ينظرون الى المشجعين او
المتجمهرين هنا حتى يتاكدوا ان لا احد
يقوم
همم بالقفز او الخروج من هذا الحاجز الذي
نجده امام ال- ال- المشجعين الكثير من
المشجعون هنا مكتوب على على نظارهم هذه
هؤلاء الشباب راموس يعني هيا بنا راموس
راموس هذا الذي نعرفه عن المنتخب
الارجنتيني والكثير منهم ياتون
رامبو مطلقه
اخيرا تحقق العلم هذه
الاجواء الشباب والسيدات والعائلات التي
تنتظر هذا وصول هذا الموقف في هذا الممر
مره اخرى على هنا بشكل حصري هذا يعني هذه
المنطقه محظوره على المرور او على المشاه
يوجد فقط مصور فوتوغرارين فوتوغرافيين هنا
في المنطقه والمصور الرسمي الذي نجد على
هذا الكرسي هناك هو الذي سيقوم بتصوير
ونقل الصوره مباشره ولكن نحن هنا في وسط
هذا الدرب وانتظار وصول الموكب بقياده
ميسي طبعا هذه لحظات تاريخيه عاد طيب
المنتخب المنتخب
مطول شويه خليني اروح وارجع لك همم
نايف الساحات الجماهير المحبين الارجنتين
يلا
عادل انا طبعا في المنطقه
المؤديه الى المنطقه
واحاول ان التقط يعني بعض الجماهير هناك
يعني جنسيات مختلفه ومتعدده
الجماهير التي تدعم المنتخب طبعا
يا مرحبا
من الامارات
وهاي بعض ضغطنا المباراه نفس السالفه
يعطيك العافيه وموفق يا عمي توصل بالسلامه
وبيض الله وجهكم مشكورين طيب انا عادل انا
احاول بتمشى واحاول التقط الجماهير
الارجنتينيه طبعا هي احتفلت في الجو
الملعب ولا اني باتجاه المترو
طبعا هذه الكلمه الوحيده
طيب نايف اليوم من كانوا خارج الملعب
كفاعلهم مع المباراه واحداثها طوال هذه
الاكثر من 120 دقيقه حتى وصول الى ضربات
الترجيح
طبعا الملعب يتسع ل 88,000 لكن عادل اليوم
اللي تواجد في المنطقه الخارجيه اكثر
بكثير من المتواجدين داخل الملعب الاف
مؤلفه من الجماهير حضرت اليوم كان هناك
يعني اغلاق اغلاق جزئي للمترو اغلاق جزء
الطرق بسبب توافد الجماهير الى منطقه
لوسيل ولكن كان هناك شاشات في مناطق
متعدده في محيط الملعب حتى
تتمكن الجماهير من مشاهده همم
المباراه احتفالات كبيره وصخب كبير
وجماهير من من جميع الجنسيات ولاحظ انه ما
زال هناك جماهير تتواجد تتوافد الى منطقه
الوسيل
يا ماما ماما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ساعتين يحتفلون فبالكاد يعني لهم نفس لكن
خليني فلتقط تفضل
هنا يعني اشكال متعدده من الجماهير
[موسيقى]
انا اعرفها بالارجنتيني بس ما ادري ناسيها
عموما قاموا يلبسون الغتره طيب خليه يروح
الى فرنسا
انتشار امني كفيف كما سمعت الاجواء ماطره
اولا الشوارع خاليه اليوم حزينه على
الفرنسيين يبدو
اليوم حزين جدا على الفرنسيينهم غادروا
تحت المطر حزينين ووجوههم متجهما بسبب
الخساره كان هناك الالاف في جده
يستعدون الاحتفال حتى كان هناك الالاف قبل
بدايه المباراه الكل نزل الى هذه الجاده
ليحجز مكانا له لانه كان من المتوقع ان
يتدفق عشرات الاف وربما 100000 من
الجماهير في حال فوز منتخب فرنسا لكن في
النهايه في النهايه هذه كره قدم خسره
المنتخب الفرنسي والكل عاده الى منزله لا
يوجد الكثير من الاشخاص فتحت حركه المرور
في السابق من قبل الشرطه لتامين
الاحتفالات كان هناك نحو 14000 شرطي نشروا
اليوم في شوارع فرنسا وخصوصا هنا في
العاصمه كان هناك نحو
2750 شرطي فقط من اجل تامين الاحتفالات في
جده لكن في النهايه لا يوجد مشجعين الشرطه
بقيت وحدها ورفعت السواتر التي كانت تسد
المداخل الى شارع الشانزليزيه همم والجميع
عد الى منزله عاده طيب يعني لم
تحدثات لماذا هذا الانتشار الامني اليوم
كان حفاظا فقط على في حال الفرح حفاظا على
اي همم تطورات
خلاص خاليه نهائيا ال- الفرنسيين بعد هذه
الخساره التقيت فيهم اصداء الخساره عندكم
معظم الفرنسيين الذين تحدثنا اليهم تقبلوا
الخساره بروح رياضيه حتى ان كان هناك في
عدد من المباشرات السابقه التي اجريتها
كان هناك مشجعين للارجنتين يمرون امام
الكاميرا ويهتفون لميسي ولا احد يتحدث
اليهم او يعترض طريقهم على العكس تماما
الكل تقبل هذه الخساره بيروح رياضيه
وبالمناسبه ايضا ربما ميسي هو السير في
هذه المساله لانه يلعب لنادي باريس سان
جيرمان وعلى اي حال هم لديهم اغنيه شهيره
تقول هاتوا الكاس الى المنزل ميسي سوف
ياتي بالكاس الى المنزل لم يذهب الى احد
غريب بالنسبه للفرنسيين لانه يلعب في نادي
باريس سان جيرمان الانتشار الامني بالعوده
الى سؤالك كان بسبب ان فرنسا لديها ذكريات
اليمه مع حوادث
مشجعين كره القدم في مونديال عام 1998
ووقع عدد من القتلى واصابات كثيره بسبب
التجمهر الكبير والتدفق الهائل الاشخاص
الذين نزلوا للاحتفال في جده
بحصول فرنسا على اا اول لقب لها لذلك كانت
هذه فقط محاوله لتنظيم الامور اكثر وايضا
لان فرنسا سوف تستضيف في 2023 مونديال
الركبي وايضا في 2024
الاولمبياد لذلك هذه المساله هي مهمه ايضا
للخارج ليس فقط لفرنسا لكي تظهر فرنسا
انها قادره على استضافه مثل هذه البطولات
وضمان سلامه الجماهير عادل شكرا جزيلا
فادي دهوك روح البيت استمتع بدف همم
المنزل شكرا جزيلا لك بعيدا عن هذا المطر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في كل النسخه من كاس العالم تحصل داخل
الفرق الفائزه على مكافات او تحصل على
مكافاه ماليه من صندوق الفيفا الذي يخصص
440 مليون دولار للفرق الفريق الفائز
بالكاس الارجنتين طبعا سيحصل على 42 مليون
دولار الفريق الخاسر في المباراه النهائيه
وهنا نتحدث عن فرنسا سيحصل على 30 مليون
دولار الفريق الحاصل على المركز الثالث
وهو منتخب كرواتيا سيحصل على 27 مليون
دولار من اموال الجائزه بينما سيحصل لفريق
المغرب الذي حصل على المركز الرابع على 25
مليون دولار لكن لا تذهب كل الاموال عاده
ثاني الى اللاعبين لكنهم يحصلون على قطعه
كبيره من الكعبه
نسخه مونديال القطار 2022 باحه باخر
اسراري هابي تتويج منتخب الارجنتين باللقب
بعد مباراه تاريخيه وصعبه نسخه هذا
المونديال شهدت الكثير من المفاجات وتركت
ورائها مشاهد ستبقى عالقه وخالده في
الذاكره
لذاكره كلهم
مشاهد لم تخلق من غرائب وطرائف سنتعرف
عليها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
في ايران المحتجون المعتقلون بين حبل
المشنقه او القتل بالرصاص
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله اليد البريطانيه الممدوده
لاوكرانيا قد تتراجع عن اهداقها بالاسلحه
هي تلميحات فقط اشاره الى الموضوع لتبد
القلق في صفوف الجيش الاوكراني لما قد
يحدثه ذلك من خلال في موازين القوى كيف له
والاسلحه الغربيه كانت من دون شك كلمه
السر في صمود الجيش الاوكراني بل وتحقيقه
للكثير من المكاسب بعد اقل من شهرين من
تنصيب ريشه معك رئيس الوزراء بريطانيا
يبدو بان رياح التغيير قد تهب على الدعم
المقدم لاوكرانيا صحيفه سبرس البريطانيه
ذكرت ان رئيس الوزراء ريشه هناك قد اثار
خوف من ان لندن ستسحب مساعداتها العسكريه
اكيد من خلال طلب به تقيما لتطورات الحرب
في اوكرانيا
الاكثر من ذلك هو استفسار سوناك عن اهميه
الامدادات العسكريه البريطانيه في هذه
الحرب وهو ما قد يشير ربما الى اتخاذ لندن
نهجا جديدا جديدا الحضارات تجاهها العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه تقول الصحيفه ذلك في
الوقت الذي تدخل فيه الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه مرحله خارجه رغم تداول هذه
التلميحات على نطاق الواسع الى مسؤولا في
الحكومه البريطانيه خرج لتحضها مؤكدا ان
هناك يدعم اوكرانيا بقوه
التلميحات القادمه من بريطانيا تاتي في
سياقه تشير فيه بعض المعطيات الاخرى عن
رغبه لندن في اعاده النظر ولو جزئيا في
علاقتها مع موسكو ما يزيد من تزكيه هذا
الطرح هو التصريحات الاخيره لرئيس هيئه
الاركان العامه البريطاني الادميرال
تونيرا دا كينج التي قال فيها انه يرغب في
قيام علاقات اقوى مع روسيا لتحقيق اقصى
فائده ووقا لصحيفه التلجرام التي اجرت
مقابله مع ارادتين بقي رئيس الاركان
العامه البريطانيه على اتصال بناغييره
الروسي فاليري جراند سيمو خلال هذا العام
على رومي من تدهور العلاقات بين
موسكوين رحب بكل فرصه على قنوات الاتصال
مفتوحه بين لندن
[موسيقى]
في الاردن
كبير الدبلوماسيين الامريكي
في اوكرانيا من خلال الدبلوماسيه محضرا من
ابعاد روسيا عن ممارسه السياسه
الاستراتيجيه وان الرغبه في تفكيك موسكو
قد تطلق العنان لفوضا نوويه عامه وذلك
مجله عفوا ناس فيكتور ال بريطانيا
مع تصاعدي حده السجلات حول هجوم روسيا
مرتب ضد اوكرانيا تطالب اطراف دوليه بوقف
الحرب عبر تسويه دبلوماسيه شامله
احد كبار الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين اشار
وحسب مجله اذا سبتيتر البريطانيه الى
ضروره وقف المواجهات والحد من نشوب حرب
عالميه
الوقت يقترب للبناء على التغيرات
الاستراتيجيه التي تحققت ودمجها في هيكل
جديد لتحقيق السلام من خلال المفاوضات
كيسنجر كان اعلن عن اقتراحات ومسارات لم
تؤيدها اوكرانيا ودول غربيه
محذرا من ان الرغبه في تفكيك روسيا قد
تطلق العنان لفوضا نوويه عامه مشددا على
عدم ابعاد روسيا عن ممارسه السياسه
الاستراتيجيه لان الامر لا يمكن ان يحول
اراضيها التي تضم 11 منطقه زمنيه الى فراغ
متنازع عليه ومخاطر حقيقيه بسبب وجود الاف
الاسلحه النوويه باعتبارها واحده من اكبر
قوتين نوويتين في العالم
وبالتزامن قدم كيسنجر
لحلول ممكنه ربما تساهم في وقف الحرب
وجدتها كيف غير مناسبه وقف النار وانسحاب
روسيا الى الخطوط الاماميه ما قبل الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير بقاء ملف شبه جزيره
القرم محل مفاوضات اجراء استفتاء تحت
اشراف دولي للبث في امر الاراضي التي
ضمتها روسيا في 2014
في المقابل قال خبراء عسكريون وامنيون ان
وقف حرب اوكرانيا يصطدم بعراقيل ابرزها
تجديد الاوكرانيين على خروج روسيا من
اراضيها كما دخلتها اول مره انسحاب الجنود
الروس من اقليم دومباس ومناطق اخرى تمثل 5
مساحه اوكرانيا
فيما تعتبر موسكو انها حققت اهداف عمليتها
الخاصه بضم اقليم دومباس الى الاتحاد
الروسي وسط تسريبات عن امكانيه تخلي روسيا
عن مناطق مثل خرسون وزابولوجيا كما فعلت
بسحب جنودها من كاركيف
هو حسب تقارير امنيه فان روسيا تواصل
توسيع نفوذها من شبه جزيره القرم الى
ضواحي روستو جنوبا فيما تحسن اوكرانيا
ترسانتها العسكريه باسلحه اوروبيه
وامريكيه لاخراج القوات الروسيه من
اراديها جاسم محسن العربيه
ينضم الينا من لندن عبر سكايب روبرت بوكس
الباحث فيها شؤون العسكريه والامنيه سيد
روبرت ما هي قراءتك لتلميح لندن با ربما
بتقليل الدعم او كفه عن كيف بالتالي هل
تريد
للحوار والجلوس على طاوله الحوار مع موسكو
افسح هذا المجال وابدا حسن النيه مثلا
تقرير للجهود بعد من رئيس الاركان الجيش
هناك اجتماع همم يوم غد مع رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني همم
المجموعه العسكريه التي ستلتقي لتفكر
بالخيارات وسيكون هناك
صعوبه لان التوقع هو ان
روسيا تعد
لهجوم جديد كبير على الاقل على جبهتين في
اوائل العامل
سقوط موسكو
سيترك فراغ هل سيتحمل الغرب هذا الفراغ
الناشئ عن عدم وجود مركزيه في موسكو
هذا لم يحدث
بريطانيا
هو اسم كبير لكنه همم من الماضي
استراتيجيات القديمه وهذه حرب اقليميه
قذره لا تنطوي عليها هذه النظريه ولكن حتى
وان مرتفع سقف هذه الحرب هناك ايضا احاديث
من ان تبقى في المستوى الميداني والتي
تطور الى المستوى النووي رغم التلميحات
سواء لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي او نظير
الروسي حتى او حتى بعض الوزراء همم
والرؤساء الغربيين
هو مجرد حديث الان الان
فمن الصعب جدا ان نرى
لاي شكل ان كان يمكن ان يكون هناك
استخدام لحرب النوويه محدوده الاثر في
منطقه البحر الاسود فمن غير المرجح ان
يحدث ذلك
فروسيا تدرك هذه الحقيقه وبالتالي فانني
اعتقد ان احد الاهداف هو توسعه الحرب
هناك
تقارير ان روسيا ستحاول ان تدفع نحو
الحدود البولنديه دون ان تعبرها
ستحيط المنطقه
وتهاجم عبر البحر الاسود
المتوقع ان يرفع من مستويات عملياته همم
من هنا
اطلع من القادم وهذا همم ما نراقبه حول
الهجمات على
البرى التحتيه والبنادق المدنيه والمدن
هذه المساله لكن بالنسبه
للوضع فهو سيبقى
تقليديا لكن بتفتكات غير تقليديه على
الاطلاق
العسكريه ولا امنيه
[موسيقى]
كشفت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه عن
مقتل نزيل واصابه 17 اخرين اثناء التصدي
باحتجاجات في سجن كرج الشمالي طهران وذكرت
المنظمه ان الاضطرابات هي الاحدث في هذا
السجن الذي يشهد عدد احتجاجات داخليه
نشيرتا الى ان هذه الاضطرابات بدات عندما
احتج السجناء على نقل معتقل الى الحبس
الانفرادي واستطع انباء عن تنفيذي حكم
الاعدام به
هذا وتستعد ايران يوم الاثنين لموجه
اضطراباتن واسعه للتواقم الطبيه احتجاجا
على مقتل الطبيبه ايدا رستومي التي اختفت
في الثانيه عشر من ديسمبر الماضي لكن
القصه تكمن في كيف قتلت رسمي التي كانت
تقدم الاسعافات الاوليه للمصابين الروايه
المشبوهه التي قدمها النظام باقدامها
باقسامها على الانتحار او تعرضها لحادث لن
تقنع هذه الروايه الايرانيين سينما وان
الجثه التي تسلمتها عائله رستومي تثبت
تعرضها للتعذيب خلال الاعتقال من قبل
النظام القصه اعاده فتح ملف المعتقلين على
خلفيه الاحتجاجات في ايران وما يتعرضون له
من تعذيب واخفاء وانعدام الرعايه الصحيه
وحرمان الزيارات العائليه
[موسيقى]
معنى منها امستردام الصحفي المختصه في شان
الايرانيه يعقوب سعيد سيد يعقوب يعني غير
قصه الاحتجاجات في الشارع التي اصبحت اشهر
وقمع المتظاهرين واربما في بعض الاحيان
الاستخدام للرصاص وتعرضهم للقتل هناك ملف
اخر وهو التعذيب في السجون الايرانيه غير
حتى لمن يقدم المساعده للمحتاجين او
يسعفهم كما حدث مع الرسم يا عيد رسمي
نعم تحيه طيبه لك مش هذه قناه العربيه بكل
تاكيد يعني انا ايضا احد اقاربي قبل اكثر
من شهرين مات تحت التعذيب عماد حيدري في
بعد ايام من اعتقاله من المنزل كذلك
الاطباء ليست فقط الى رست بالكثير من
الاطباء الذين يسعفون الحالات المصابين
بانهم بالتالي هؤلاء المصابين لا يسمح لهم
للذهاب الى المستشفيات يتم اعتقالهم عند
ذهابه من المستشفياتها يضطرون الى
الاستعانه باطباء وحتى في بعض الاحيان
طبقين كثير من الاطباء تم اعتقالهم نتيجه
انهم
حاولوا اسعاف المرضى او المصابين في
منازلهم ايدرستم مثلا على سبيل المثال الى
ما راينا التناقضات في روايات النظام
هنالك ثلاث روايات متناقضه ادلاء النظام
خلال ساعات اولها تقول بانهم بانها ماتت
نتيجه الصدامها بجسم صلب ثانيه تقول
انتحار التي تقول بانهم القول القبض على
شخص تم اعتقال تم همم مشتبه به بقتلها هذا
بينما اكدت عائله هذه انها بانها وجدوا
اثار تعذيب على جسدها على جسد هذه الطبيبه
في في ايران وكذلك هي ايضا عائله تاكدت
بانها قدمت مساعدات للمصابين في يعني خارج
المستشفيات فبالتالي النظام الايراني اصبح
يستهدف الجميع حقيقه انا لاطباء وكذلك
المهندسين جميع الاشخاص الذين يستطيعون ان
يقدموا مساعده المحتاجين اليوم يعني احنا
ننتظر اضراب قد يقوم فيه الجسم الطبي
نتيجه لما حدث لايدرسومي هل سيواجهون ذات
المصير هل يقدم النظام على الاقل على
اعتقالهم
بكل تاكيد يعني اذا ما اخذنا مثلا
بالرياضيين الرياضيين عندما
اقدموا على حالات يعني تضامن مع المحتجين
احد الاشخاص الرياضيين هو الان حكم عليه
بالاعدام فكذلك مصير الاطباء لن يكون
مختلفا وبالتالي ولكن اتصور بانهم ايضا
وصلوا الى نتيجه بان حياتهم معرضه
فبالتالي الكثير من الاطباء تم اعتقالهم
ايضا رستم مثلا ماتت همم لذلك هم ايضا
هؤلاء الاطباء صحيح من الناحيه
الاقتصاديين على المستوى الاقتصادي ولكن
على المستوى الاجتماعي على المستوى
السياسي بتلمعانوا من حاله ديكتاتوريه هذه
الثوره ايضا تعبر عن مطالبهم لذلك تضامنهم
هذه الثوره هم يرونه علينا واجب وليس
تضامن
للمحتش الشارع وليس دعما لحق
وق بلهوم بل هم جزء لا يتجازا من هذه
الثوره كما الكثير من الشرائح
المشتمله شكرا للصحفيه المختص في الشان
الايرانيه يعقوب سعيد من امسدام
[موسيقى]
دانت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه الهجوم على
قوه الامن العراقيه بشمال البلاد الذي ادى
الى مقتل ثمانيه من افراد الشرطه بينهم
ضابط في كمين داعش جنوبه محافظه كركوك يوم
الاحد واكدت الخارجيه في بيان النقلته
وكاله الانباء السعوديه عن رفض المملكه
لكل اشكال العنف والاعمال الارهاببيه
وجددتها الخارجيه دعم السعوديه لكل جهود
الراميه الى القضاء على الارهاب والتطرف
بجميع اشكاله وصوره وتجفيه في منابع تمويل
[موسيقى]
شدد رئيس الوزراء الاردني بشرى الخصاونه
على ان حق التعبير عن الراي مقفول بموجب
الدستور لكنه اكد ان سياده القانون لا
تقبل المساومه واشار الى ان هناك رغبه
دائما لدى الحكومه بدعم المواطنين وخفض
اسعار السلع لكن ذلك غير ممكن في ظل ظروف
الاقتصاديه الحاليه من جانبه واجهه وزير
الداخليه الاردني المحافظين بوقف الملاحقه
الامنيه لاي شخص شارك في الاعتصامات او
الوقفات الاحتجاجيه السلبيه خلال فتره
الماضيه واكد ان القرار لا يشمل الاشخاص
الذين قاموا باطلاق العيارات الناريه او
ارتكاب اعمال عنف او اعتدوا على الممتلكات
العامه والخاصه
هذا مقتله الضابط الاردني عبد الرزاق
الدلابيح الاردن الامو رحيله كان صعبا على
امه التي فقدت ثلاثه من ابنائها قبل موته
ولدته عبد الرزاق لقبت بخنساء الاردن
بوداعها ابنها الرابع العقيده الذي قتل
برصاصه اعمال شغب في محافظه معان احتجاجا
على ارتفاع اسعار المشتقات النفطيه
ان كان الحزن بقدر الالم فصبر هذه الام
فاق مصابها ودعت ابنها الوداع على اخيره
راضيه النفسي قبل الفراق
الاردني
دارت في محافظه معان على خلفيه ارتفاع
اسعار المشتقات النفطيه ودع الدلابيحه
الحياته ممتحنا بوداعه صبر امه فقد
الثلاثه من ابنائها قبل رحيله صابره للمره
الرابعه على هذا المصاب
ربي ما ودهني
ربي يقول لي
يصبر به يا ربي ينطيني
فوق ياخذ جزابيه ومن كل اهله ومن كل
عرفانه ومن كل شقيق حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
فيك اخذ مني قطعه من قلبي اخذ مني اخذ مني
اكثر حدا بحبه
كل يوم ما بتعرف تنام
على النفس
اليوم صليت الفجر صليت الفجر
في حفيد السلامه
[موسيقى]
العربيه
لدينا في اخبار الساعه في ايضا
بعد الظهر بكاس العالم ميسي يعلن مواصله
مسيرته الدوليه
[موسيقى]
اعلن اللاعب الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي
مواصله مسيرته الدوليه كاس العالم اليوم
حصل على لقب افضل لاعب كره القدم في
مونديال 22 قبل ان توجه الى الموجز الرياض
نتابع معكم مشاهدينا الاحتفالات الكبيره
المستمره فيديو فوز منتخب الارجنتين على
فرنسا وتتويج الارجنتين ببطوله كاس العالم
2022 الالاف كما نرى يشاركونا في هذه
الاحتفالات
[موسيقى]
هلال العناوين
اداءنا بحجم نهائي كاس العالم هلا ارجنتين
تنتزع الفوز من فرنسا بركلات الترجيح
وتتوج بطله بعد 36 عاما
بعد قتال شرس حتى النفس الاخير بابي هداف
مونديال 22 وميسي افضل لاعب
بريطانيا تتخذ نهجا حذرا في حرب اوكرانيا
وتلمح اليقف الدعم العسكري لكيب وتبدي
تقاربا جزئيا
خنساء الاردن تودع ابنها الرابعه العربيه
تلتقي الوالده والده الضابط الذي قتل في
اعمال الشعب الاخيره
شكرا لكم لطيب المتابعه في امان الكريم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]